Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and Welcome back to
Crash Course, Statistics.
We have to wait for a lot of things in life.
We wait until we’re old enough to live on
our own, or go to college, or drive a car.
Waiting can suck, and it’s even worse when
you don’t know how long you’ll have to wait.
Luckily, in certain situations, probabilities
can help you guess how long it might take
for something to happen, like getting a full
house in poker, having your first daughter,
or winning the lottery.
INTRO
For example, you’re eating from a box of
Bertie Bott’s Every Flavour Beans during
a fun, if risky, hang out with your friends.
These Jelly Beans have some flavors that are awesome like Cherry and Peppermint, and some
not so awesome like Grass, or Boogers, or
Vomit. Ewww.
The problem: you don’t know if you’re
gonna get a good or gross flavor until you eat it.
And you know that your affinity for this game will go away if you’re ever unlucky enough
to come across one of those Vomit flavored
beans.
Cinnamon!
It's delicious.
But how likely is it that you’ll be able
to eat 4 of these odd Jelly Beans before you
get that dreaded Vomit flavor and decide to
get new friends?
Turns out, there’s a formula to do this.
The Geometric Probability Formula.
This formula comes from The Geometric Probability Distribution, which looks similar to the Binomial
Probability Distribution that we talked about in the last episode.
But they do something a little bit different.
Geometric probabilities tell you the probability that your first success will be on your nth try.
And success here just means the event we’re interested in happens, it’s not always a good thing.
For example, the probability that your first
Vomit flavored jelly bean will be your 5th
Jelly Bean this means that the first 4 beans
were all not vomit flavored.
Let’s pretend the probability of getting
a Vomit flavored bean is 5%, then there’s
a 95% chance that you’ll get any other flavor.
As you remember from the multiplication rule.
Our chance of getting four non-vomit beans in a row is 0.95 x .95 x .95 x .95 or .95^4.
The probability of then getting the Vomit
bean is 0.05, so all together, the probability
of getting 4 non-vomit beans and
then 1 Vomit flavored bean is this or about 4.07%
In a more general form, The Geometric Probability Formula says that the probability of the kth
try being your first success, is the probability of failure to the k-1 power, times the probability
of success to the first power.
Which is what we just did in the vomit jellybean example..
The probability of the 5th try being your
first success was the probability of 5-1 or
4 failures and then one success.
If we graph the geometric probability for
all possible values of k, we get a Geometric
distribution that shows us the probability
of each trial being the first time we get a success.
For example let’s look at a section of the
geometric distribution for finding the probability
that each trial is the first time we’d eat
a vomit flavored jelly bean.
You’ll notice that I said “a section of”
because the geometric distribution could go
on forever technically we could eat thousands of Bertie’s Beans and still not find any
Vomit Flavored ones...in fact that’s pretty
much what I hope when I eat them.
It’s just very unlikely, which we can see
on our graph.
As k increases, the probability of that being
your first success gets incredibly low, mostly
because you’ll probably have found the flavor that shall not be named already.
Let’s look at another example: You’re
finishing up basketball practice and your
coach announces that you’ll have to make
one free throw before you can leave.
You’re really bad at free throws, and you
have a 20% probability of making any given shot.
So we can calculate the probability that the
first shot you make is your 10th shot.
Plugging everything into our formula, we discover that the probability of this particular scenario
is this: or about 2.7%.
The Geometric distribution for this example looks like this which gives us all the probabilities
that a certain trial is the first time you
make a shot: But you’d also get to leave
if you made it before your 10th shot.
To calculate the probability that you’ll
have to shoot 10 or fewer free throws before
you make one, we can add up all the geometric probabilities from 1 up to 10.
This essentially tells us the probability
that it takes k or fewer tries before your
first success which you might remember from when we talked about cumulative distributions.
A cumulative geometric distribution is incredibly useful because often when we ask questions
about how long we have to wait for a certain outcome, we want to consider whether it happens
before the nth trial.
Like we said, whether it’s the first or
10th shot, you still get to leave practice,
and it turns out that there’s a 89.3% chance
that before your 10th shot, You will have
made a basket.
That make for a total of about 92% chance
that you’d make it on or before your 10th shot.
If you want to find the average number of
shots you need to take before you score, you
can use the geometric distribution to calculate its mean, which is 1 divided by the probability
of success or this.
The mean number of shots we’d need to take before we made our first would be
1/0.2, which is 1/(1/5) or 5.
And this makes some sense.
The smaller the probability of success is,
the more tries we’ll need--on average--before
we get a success.
For example, if there’s only a 10% chance
that we’d make the shot, we’re really
bad basketball players we’d now need
to try an average of 1/(1/10) or 10 throws
before we sink that perfect shot.
The mean and cumulative frequency of the geometric distribution can help you weigh your options.
Say you’re at Target, and you see the display of Pokemon cards.
You really want that Pikachu card, but let’s
say that the probability of getting one is
1/200.
You have enough money to either buy 4 packs of cards, or Star Wars Episode VI on Blu-Ray.
Star Wars guarantees ewoks.
Pokemon means maybe Pikachu.
You’re really into small cute animals...small
cute animals with Static ability...even better.
You want that Pikachu.
Is is worth it?
If each pack of Pokemon cards has 10 cards, you’ll have 40 cards, each with a 1/200
chance of being a coveted Pikachu.
The probability that you wouldn’t get a
Pikachu until your 40th card is only about
.04 %, but the cumulative probability that
you’d get a Pikachu on your 40th card or
earlier is about 18%, which isn’t bad.
So now you’re left to decide whether it’s
worth it to forgo an evening with ewoks for
an 18% shot at getting your beloved Pikachu.
That part is something statistics can’t
decide for you.
Before we wrap up probability...let’s look
a really fun statistical paradox...the birthday paradox.
There are 365 birthdays that anyone can have, we’re not going to count leap days-- to
keep things simple.
So let’s say there are 20 people in your
classroom.
What’s the likelihood that there would be
any shared birthdays?
To me...it seemed like it’d be pretty low.
Let’s assume that there’s an equal probability of having a birthday on each day of the year.
That’s not quite true, but it’s close
enough.
The first person we look at has a 100% chance of having a unique birthday, simply because
we haven’t looked at anyone else yet.
The second person also has a pretty high chance of having a unique birthday, they could be
born on any of the 364 days on which person #1 wasn't born, so there’s a 364/365 chance
of having a unique birthday.
Similarly person #3 can be born on any of
the 363 days on which neither person #1 or
person #2 are born, so there’s a 363/365
chance that they’ll have a unique birthday as well.
And this pattern continues for all the people in the room.
By the 20th person, there is a 346/365 chance that they have a unique birthday.
Using the multiplication rule, we know that
the probability of ALL of these events happening--in
other words each person having a unique birthday-- is the product of all these probabilities.
So the probability that everyone has a unique birthday is about 59%.
That means that the other 41% of the time
at least two people will share a birthday.
Once you get up to a group of 70 there’s
a 99.9% chance of someone will be sharing a birthday with someone else.
This is one of those instances where statistics trumps my own intuition.
And a good reason to be prepared for the possibility of double cupcakes if you have a big class.
Probabilities are important.
They’re things we use all the time.
When you’re at your local diner and see
those super cool Crane machines, you might
estimate the probability that you can snag
that sweet stuffed otter by the time your
food arrives and whether it’s worth your
time and money to even try.
Or you can use them to figure out that on
average, you’ll probably have to wait a
looooong time before you win the California State Lottery , like a really long time, on
average it should take you about 15 million
tries.
That’s a lot o’ lotto tickets.
Brandon made me say that.
Geometric probabilities, and probabilities
in general, allow you to guess how long you’ll
have to wait for something, so you can decide whether it’s worth it.
As the famous mathematician Pierre-Simon Laplace once said, probability “is basically just
common sense reduced to calculus; it makes one appreciate with exactness that which accurate
minds feel with a sort of instinct, often
without being able to account for it.”
In other words, it allows us to quantify things we already feel.
Probability assigns numbers to common sense.
And we all need a little more of that.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time.